[Music]
alright hey everyone
uh welcome to my awesome talk as I was
just introduced my name is Ashley
Williams but you may know me as a g-dubs
from the internet and if you do I am
sorry but I do not have a lot of time
and I've got a lot of content so let's
just jump right into it what is this
talk about this talk is about a couple
of things the first thing it is about is
performance but more importantly
performance that makes things more
accessible and unlike a lot of the talks
that we've seen at this conference
this talk is also about infrastructure
can I get a shout out from any of the
ops people in the room come on who's on
page or duty right now all right someone
I'm so sorry that sucks but in a general
thing I also want this talk to be a
little bit about how the internet works
and potentially how the internet could
work and so this talk is called
JavaScript journey to the edge and so
there's a little bit of journeying as
well perhaps you're more familiar with
this journeys if you're from the United
States but I wanted to say just a small
thing as this is jeaious comps at least
last for the moment talk about how
important this conference has been to me
first off I spoke at the last reject j/s
in 2015 and I was the second to last
reject only to mari Koh who was the last
reject and it was one of the most
amazing conferences the next day I went
to Jay's Kampf EU and promptly saw
someone wearing a shirt with my face on
it which was a fascinating surprise and
this was from a musical number they had
done using some quotes from a previous
talk of modding and they did that again
in 2017 or 2016 with the classic people
got mad which was an auto-tuned of my
voice talking about how people get mad
if you put all your code in one file
they do get mad so but then I spoke at J
is confident 2017 and I warned Antipa
shirt because I thought that was rad and
this is
place you can do that it was a super fun
talk and man I have so many friends at
this conference the last time I was here
was last year where I did an impromptu
rust and web assembly workshop for about
a hundred people from the Mozilla booth
and it's cool cuz someone published
their first NPM package and I had web
assembly in it and so this conference is
super awesome so can we just give it a
round of applause I love this place but
this talk is obviously not about my
journey this talk is about JavaScript's
journey so I'm about to show you some
very scientific timelines that I made
using Wikipedia and keynote so
javascript has had a really fascinating
kind of history and a lot of people have
talked about history because of this
being the tenth one and node being
announced in 2009 or 2009 that's fine
you can say it like that but we've seen
a lot of development from JavaScript and
we've seen it develop really really
quickly and I think it's gonna developed
in one particular way so here we see the
first website in 1991 and then we end
with wasm up in 2017 by the way ohmygod
wiesen was only born in 2017 amazing but
we also saw the appearance of a fair
number of things including a lot of
browser engines and a lot of frameworks
and I think one of the most pivotal
things in this this timeline that people
don't usually see is that the emergence
of Google Maps in 2004 really motivated
people to see what you could do inside
of a website and made it so that we
started developing all of these things
you could do browser computation so much
faster
so if we put these graphs together and
we take a look at this what's happening
is that the speed of computation in the
browser is just exponentially growing
and that is so awesome and I I'm a big
webassembly fan I'm super here for this
however because the browser has become
such a computationally awesome agent
we've run into some costs how much does
doing this cost and
this comes back to the idea of
accessibility and it's spelled wrong
here but it really comes down to the
fact that what we're talking about is
the ability for people to even access
content and so addy Osmani and has
talked the cost of JavaScript in 2018
said the web is bloated by user
experience and he is genuinely
completely right so how many people here
have ever checked out HTTP archive if
you haven't it is amazing and you should
look at these numbers this is just one
of the graphs but what this graph is
showing is the median size of desktop
and mobile applications with the
JavaScript bytes that are being
downloaded to the device and we have
seen a 353 percent increase for desktop
and it's worse for mobile five five
hundred and seventy-seven percent growth
in how much we're sending to the browser
and that's cool because remember the
browser can take that stuff and it can
compute it really fast but moving those
bytes over the wire takes a lot of time
and so on average remember this is on
average there's people who are on the
really bad end of this mobile loading
time for an average website takes nine
seconds all right
that's unacceptable and so this is gonna
be part of the problem we're gonna solve
in my talk today so my intro did not
entirely say this but I am a systems
engineer for a big orange cloud not to
be confused with a big orange website
which I am not a fan of or SoundCloud
which has a surprisingly similar logo I
work for this thing called CloudFlare
and I know the cloud doesn't look super
big here it's in perspective right so
what does cloud flare do clouds there is
a infrastructure company it's what that
plugs were is not super good at actually
defining what it does but the thing you
definitely don't call it is a DNS
company because also I mean no one likes
DNS I can't ever figure that out I work
at a DNS company now and I DNS man but
we call ourselves an infrastructure
company and sometimes I describe
CloudFlare as a hardware company and
that is because our primary asset
is this and this is a map of a hundred
and eighty data centers and growing all
over the world and so this set of data
centers contains something which is
called the edge and this is a terrible
name it like doesn't make any sense to
most people someone said there's a
wrestler called the edge I don't know
who that is
whatever but to cry and talk to you
about what the edge is we're going to
talk about one of the classic
dichotomies in web programming client
and server and to do so let's talk about
pizza who likes pizza all right there we
go
I'm originally from New York so Pizza is
cool right
we're gonna talk about pizza delivery
and I want you to view that in the eyes
of pizza accessibility cuz it would be
terrible to deny people pizza right
especially warm fresh pizza right so
obviously you got smoosh those together
for pizza accessibility all one word
alright so we're gonna do some
animations here here's a small key your
JavaScript program is going to be
represented by this lovely chef your
JavaScript program executing is the bang
emoji your JavaScript programs generated
output is a pizza your end user is a
superhero because this is how we should
always think about our users and we're
gonna have this interesting thing that's
a basket and so there you can kind of
think of that as like a data center a
point of presence or a cache note all
right so let's take a look at what
client-side rendering looks like
so with client-side rendering what we do
is we have our chef in New York and we
have our person who wants to eat pizza
in Australia and when we'd render on the
client we send the chef to Australia
that's a lot right and then what the
chef has to do is then the chef has to
cook and then at that point you have
delivered your pizza in Australia but
that's a little concerning right like
maybe the person who Australia doesn't
have like a whole room with like an oven
for a chef to move in and start cooking
like maybe they have a flip phone that
could literally can't do that and so
this is a little bit of a complicated
situation all right so of course what do
we do let's store a cache on it that
should make it better right so instead
with our cache or
we send our chef to a basket you know in
the Pacific Ocean right the South
Pacific right we send the whole chef
right and then we still have to send the
whole chef to Australia where they cook
and they make their pizza so again we
still have this situation even with a
cache so the chef is traveling for maybe
a closer location but they still have to
go into that person's house and make
that pizza that's pretty invasive I
think all right so we can just keep
sending those chefs but yeah so again we
have another option right we have
server-side rendering and of course as
everyone said ten years ago @j has come
for you Ryan Dahl announced nodejs and
nodejs was super cool because it kind of
promised to unify web development on
both the client and the server it was
like why are we doing this in two
languages let's do it in one all right
and that made the server accessible to
JavaScript developers maybe not for the
first time but certainly for the first
time for anyone who didn't necessarily
want to learn a new language so let's
take a look at what server-side
rendering looks like all right so we got
our chef in New York and we've got our
superhero in Australia they're gonna
cook in New York no more moving into the
house to make pizza and then they're
gonna send that right on over not bad
but that's a pretty long trip for some
pizza right I'm not sure that's gonna
hold up fresh pizza is very important
all right so maybe that's not the
freshest of pizzas so let's throw a
cache on it right cool we'll throw cash
on it so cool the chef can still make
their pizza in New York and now they can
just send it on over to that cache and
the pizza can hang out there and then
our australia person can happily eat all
the pizza they would like but that pizza
maybe it's a little old I don't know
what if they wanted an extra topping on
something they'd have to go all the way
back and that's really not efficient and
so when we talk about the client server
and we've heard many other people talk
about this at this conference already is
that we're seeing frameworks realize
that they have to negotiate this
boundary better but that's really only
just starting and we're still genuinely
talking about these trade-offs between
the client and the server and their
tricky trade-offs now it wouldn't be an
Ashley Williams talk if what I said
trade-offs I didn't immediately start
talking about dialectics whoo who here
knows what a dialectic is all right yeah
only the people who've seen me talk
before right
okay daya what all right I'm gonna try
and go through this quick but I think
it's super important so there's this
idea of formal logic right where you say
a equals a right this is a thing and
then that thing is always equal to this
thing and we use this a lot in science
when we do this we say hey when we reach
a contradiction maybe we're a doesn't
equal a we are wrong right a does not
equal a however I think that this is
completely backwards
in fact the dialectical method in
contrast to the method of formal logic
trains us to identify these
contradictions and thereby gets to the
bottom of changes taking place
fundamentally the idea of dialectics is
that the motor of history is these
opposition's and that resolving those
opposition's and pushing them forward as
the synthesis of the opposition's is
what makes things happen and I get so
excited about this because I am a giant
philosophy nerd and so this is the
philosophy nerd version of the diagram
but I think this one will probably go
over a little bit better just wait for
it this is going to explain everything
there we go
dialectics right and so what I want us
to see here is that we've been kind of
assuming this trade-off between client
and server for a very long time and then
maybe that dichotomy is the problem all
right so we've got this problem stuff is
slow we've got the client we've got the
server we they seem to be in opposition
we have no way to resolve them what is
to be done so as I told you I work for a
big orange cloud and this big orange
cloud has a ton of baskets all over the
earth and so one day they were like hey
what should we do with all these baskets
right we've been storing static assets
in them but maybe we could do something
cooler and yeah this is a direct quote
just kidding as not direct quote at all
so what this became was like we have the
client and the server let's kind of
those opposition's synthesize them and
create the edge so let's take a look at
what that looks like we're back to pizza
all I hope you're into it all right so
with edge side rendering we have this
basket and we have the chef and the
shift just lives in the basket right and
here's the thing in all of our previous
examples
no one could cook in the basket but with
edge side rendering you can cook in the
basket and so now the chef doesn't have
to move into your house and make pizza
they can hang out in the basket that's
near your house make you pizza and then
deliver it to you that's pretty sweet
but this kind of looks a lot like
server-side rendering a little bit right
like it's just one but the real trick is
remember we don't just have one basket
we have a lot of baskets and so at any
point in time these chefs can be making
pizza and sending them to people all
over the world so everybody can have
pizza that's nice and fresh without
someone messing up their kitchen and
that's what the edge sprinkler is so you
might be asking this is a talk about
performance how fast are you right so
benchmarks are dumb and bad but I'm
gonna show you some your mileage may
vary these were done yesterday who knows
what's gonna happen tomorrow but these
are generally good representative
benchmarks of what we have so there's
something called serverless benchmark
comm I think but
these are some competitive numbers but I
don't really want to do a product talk
where I compete against other products
I'm just gonna kind of skip over that
one and I'm gonna do what I call big
numbers are big small numbers are small
our numbers are small so these are
numbers for response times in Capetown
and so a worker will respond in about
143 milliseconds and just a github pages
page is gonna respond in 591 in doha
worker will spawned in 44 milliseconds
and github pages 497 milliseconds what
about Australia all right a worker 208
milliseconds github
ages 624 those are some big numbers and
remember these are people accessing the
Internet maybe you'll call me a
millennial but if I don't have access to
the Internet I actually get nervous so
emotional health but I mean also it's
all of this information all of the
ability to prosper currently on earth is
largely driven by the Internet so this
access matters could you imagine having
to wait that much more time just to get
I don't know you probably read reddit
your reddit it would have to wait so
long it would be terrible all right
Reykjavik Iceland even 34 milliseconds
for a worker github pages 170
milliseconds so now you're probably
asking me how do you do that that is
very interesting or hopefully you think
it's interesting and so let's talk a
little bit about it so we have all of
these baskets and it turns out that
trying to cook pizza on these baskets
actually has a lot of really fascinating
constraints and so the first thing we
can think about is scalability so for
CloudFlare scalability traffic or
requests are super easy our network is
huge I think you can take over like 30
terabytes of traffic over it it's a lot
and it's continuing to grow however for
this model to work this idea of tenants
or how many apps we can put in each one
of those baskets is super hard every app
needs to be in every location for us and
some places are very small so we're
looking at a need for like around a
hundred times efficiency then what you
usually see in like a server side
offering and so we came up with a set of
constraints the first was for the code
footprint like the base amount of what
the app needs to be a VM requires 10
gigabytes a container around 100
milliwatts and then what we really
needed was less than one less than one
that's a pretty big deal all right and
then for memory usage a vm is gonna
require at least one gig a container
again around the same that ahead for the
footprint but we needed to do under five
all right and this is fundamentally
because the edge is not a large place or
as I hear the kids call it the edge is
not thick
at all it's very small and we have to
get everyone's apps on here because we
want everyone to be super fast all right
additionally because of the needs that
we have context switching is a very
interesting thing so for a VM very low
context switching is needed maybe for a
container a little bit more but like we
need super super high context switching
and this is because each of our servers
only has to run each of the apps only
has to run the requests local to it
right so we don't need to be running
that app all the time we need to be able
to switch back and forth between apps
incredibly quickly like to the point
where like switching processes would be
too much overhead that's a pretty big
constraint all right and so finally
startup time is a really fascinating
constraint a VM is probably going to
take around 10 seconds a container
around 500 milliseconds we need it to be
less than someone will notice around one
fiftieth of a blink of an eye all right
and why do we need that well if people
start using too many resources on our
edge we need to be able to kick them out
quick but if they get another request in
we need to be able to start them back up
quickly again in a way that the user
would never notice all right so these
are some pretty serious constraints
right but there's other things that also
have these same constraints for example
certain API is particularly api's that
speak to other api's may need to run
client code directly on the server
because it needs to be more efficient
similar with big data processing with
big data you can't bring the data to the
app you bring the app to the data and so
it's very similar constraints to what we
have and then also web browsers also
have the exact same constraints they
need to be constantly running all of
that code from all of those websites
that you go to that all of you are
writing and this is where I say web
browsers are freaking awesome we have
actually already solved this incredibly
fascinating server-side need
with a client-side technology like
server technologies actually too slow
and in building out server-side
technology have we just kind of
overlooked the fact that we have this
beautiful technology that's our client
for the web browsers are optimized for
exactly the types of things that we need
in a type of server list platform
they're great at small downloads they've
got fast startup someone's literally
sitting there waiting for it and so
they're gonna be moving quick remember
we talked about computation in the
browser and how optimized and great it's
been getting all right additionally I
don't know about you but I usually have
around a hundred tabs open at once and
so that's a heck of a lot of processes
but you also have to remember that a
single page all right that is not always
a single website there's plenty of
iframes that facebook like button is its
own little context and so the browser is
our orchestrating all of that and then
additionally and I know that people are
gonna fight me on this browsers are
optimized for secure isolation when you
go to a website if it was able to leak
all that stuff out to all of your other
websites we would be in a big big
problem
and so Kenton Varda the architect of
this runtime has said web browsers have
been the most hostile security
environment for quite some time and I'm
glad to agree with him on this I think
that this makes sense and so with
deciding what we were gonna do for our
service runtime we picked v8 come on Oh
fine Benedict Boyer loves the v8 joke
gosh
he runs the v8 team anyways so we chose
to build our service runtime on v8
primarily using this idea of a class of
v8
isolate now you could traditionally
actually think of this more like a VM
but the word VM has kind of changed and
so this is more like a JVM which is not
quite the same you can understand it as
kind of a lightweight context sandbox
and so why is this better than VMs or
containers and it's basically because
you get to share more it's like a little
bit more communist right VMs
you get the hardware virtualized and
then you've got to bring everything else
on your own containers all right you get
the operating system but again bringing
everything else on your own with
isolates you get web platform api's the
jeaious runtime an operating system
hardware and you just show up with your
application and maybe a couple of weird
libraries you wrote and that's freaking
awesome and because we can share so much
we can very efficiently use resources
and so just as you kind of look at what
this is in a virtual machine you can see
that the process overhead is one-to-one
with the user code whereas with the
isolate model you can see it's
definitely many to one and this is how
we are getting those benchmarks that we
are talking about so in addition to
using v8 we have built a coding and verb
for you that uses the fetch API and the
serviceworker api i you can build it out
in a UI that looks a little bit like
this you literally just have to have
something that listens for fetch events
and then you can write a function that
will handle requests you can do plenty
of other things but this is like the
bare minimum worker and what it looks
like
additionally because we're using v8 we
get webassembly for free heck yeah so if
Java scripts not your jam feel free to
use a language that targets webassembly
and we can also use that and so what you
might be thinking potentially is hey
this looks a lot like an operating
system and man I would like to talk
about how that's true but I have
literally no time left so I would
recommend that you check this out if you
want to learn about how we've tried to
tame the oom killer that's always really
fun but before I finish up I do want to
say hey is this a good idea right like
oh cool you can do it but like should
you and so a lot of people will be like
oh yes there is a specter haunting this
architecture right wrong talk sorry this
one Specter it is a fascinating memory
bug I unfortunately don't have time to
go into explaining it but what I will
tell you is that we've made some
mitigations to
you attempt to avoid it Spectre is a bug
that goes all the way down to the depths
of the stack and many of us are just
trying to cope as you kind of pop up it
and so this is what we've been doing so
far primarily we're trying to avoid
letting you have any sort of timer so no
date dot now if you use data now and a
worker it will just tell you the same
time every time we also don't allow
local concurrency because that's a timer
in disguise but one of the things that
we're also able to do is we also have
the freedom to reschedule we can take
the look at someone who's kind of
looking a little weird a worker that's
behaving funny and we can just say hey
let's let's kick you out keep an eye on
you stick you in your own little box so
hopefully I have encouraged you to think
that this is a somewhat cool technology
and that it's fast and maybe you want to
use it because you want to get fresh
pizza to everybody in the world but
let's talk about how you can actually
use it because accessibility isn't just
about receiving content it's about being
able to build content that other people
can receive and so I joined Glenn Fleur
about two months ago and diced
immediately it was like oh shoot we got
to make this developer experience way
better people do not like curl commands
with API keys in them like that's not
cool all right
so you may have seen me on a couch
yesterday but I I've been working on
this tool called Wrangler it was
originally released for building rust
web assembly workers on CloudFlare but
is now a full-fledged CLI for uploading
any type of worker you would like I just
found this picture of a crab with a
cowboy hat on it's so good
you can npm install it and it will just
work for you it looks a little bit like
this
I couldn't speed this gif up boom so if
you like emojis there's a lot of them
but if your terminal doesn't support
then we have fallback additionally we've
set up a template gallery because maybe
you don't know what you want to build
with something like this and so you can
just generate one of these templates and
get going with it each one will be will
create an actual functional worker for
you and so that's pretty awesome
and so you can run this command and just
publish and it'll be successfully
published at this fascinating URL how
many people here signed up
for workers dev sub-domain all right we
got like three so here's the thing
remember that [ __ ] DNS tweet
I hate setting up DNS maybe you do too
to get started playing with this kind of
thing you do not need to set up any sort
of DNS we will give you a free sub
domain on workers dev you can get it by
running the regular subdomain command
and snag that for you and then you can
just put all the apps and workers you
would like on it so finally we've got
some cool new docks the docks are also
written as a worker so dogfooding is
good and the big announcement here is
you probably like why do I care about
this oh this is a company corporate
product announcement but today we're
making it free so I'm really excited
because cloud floor workers are actually
the first free edge serverless platform
you cannot put something on the edge be
it our edge or someone else's edge
without paying some money and so I am
super excited to get people playing in
this brand-new awesome spot because I
think it's really gonna change how we
think about building applications
particularly building applications is a
more distributed thing across the world
and not having to think about server and
client so we have a free tier this is
some stuff about it again
go forth and build but I have one final
message for you so I'm not done and I am
almost certainly over time but it's an
Ashleigh top so we're gonna go over
because I want us to do some thinking
like it's cool this edge thing like it's
free and like I want you to go use it
and like build awesome accessible apps
but the real point of this talk is that
I want people to think more radically
and with more people who don't look like
us about how the internet works and how
it could work right when we encounter
trade-offs like the client and the
server I think a lot of people often are
just like that's how it is that's what
we have to do right of course we have
the client server we can't change that
but I want to encourage you to find out
positions like that and challenge them
because those opposition
our opportunities for making strides in
accessibility for the web like what
we're doing today and so again we've
talked about journeys we've talked about
performance we've talked about
accessibility the web is the primary
place that new developers go to learn so
let's make sure we can get there fast
the future where the j/s community is
representative of the whole world
literally cannot come soon enough thanks
[Applause]
[Music]